at this video this is Russian witch says
her magic doesn't work on Muslims so
let's see what she has to say she looks
like a professional witch so let's check
it out it's more difficult to influence
a person if he keeps his thoughts in
Purity yes absolutely one faced with
various religions it is very difficult
to influence Muslims whatever God wants
will happen to me no witch can control
it no outside entity can control it no
Jin can trick me no shaan can get in the
way of what God is doing in my life and
in my reality and if you think in that
way and if you truly believe it in
you came across this channel called hand
meditation uh of these two individuals
two couples if I'm not mistaken and they
are reacting to a video that I reacted
to of a Russian magician trying to do s
on Muslims and she says that the
aggregor whatever is some kind of a form
of barrier some Dome Etc energy force
whatever you want to call it that
protects them so she's saying anytime
she tries to do they are basically
reacting to that reaction they are
reacting to that video so we're just
going to see little snippet of it and
then inshallah I want to inshah gift
them a prayer mat why because they do
meditation and as you guys know our
guided prayer mat Salah Plus today is
the day of ARA brothers and sisters we
are building a brand new app and website
Salah plus where people are going to the
20,000 prayer M that we ordered they are
going to order them through the app they
are going to book Salah instructors from
there they're going to book Quran
instructors from there they're going to
find their local Salah hubs that we're
opening all around the UK and Europe
there's going to be videos visual videos
of how to pra Salah imagine you are a
part of all of this for the next 10 20
30 years where the app is been built
thanks to your donations today launch
SCH has told us if we can raise
£15,000 they are going to give us an
extra £75,000 brothers and sisters we
are doing a live appeal you probably
watching this video we're doing a live
please please I urge you guys to donate
whatever you can imagine you are the
reason why your £5 your £10 your ,000
your £3,000 or1 whatever it is went
towards this app that is going to be a
for the coming years and not only that
our app has Salah reminders best time to
pray Salah and even a free uh add free k
finder inallah please go and donate
right now inah and let's reach that
Target here is the video Let's watch it
for ourself hello guys I am Han this is
my wife Kelly we are Han meditations
we're back with another video we talked
to a pagan who believes in witchcraft he
believes in worshiping different gods
different deities he's uh friends with
the Jin apparently and we've been just
thinking about what is going on in this
world and why do certain religions
protect you from demons and from the
devil more than others like why is that
the case so we're looking at this video
this is Russian witch says her magic
doesn't work on Muslims so let's see
what she has to say she looks like a
professional witch so let's check it's
more difficult to influence a person if
he keeps his thoughts in Purity yes
absolutely one faced with various
religions it is very difficult to
influence Muslims they are in a constant
connection with the aggregor they do
namas every day and read prayers on a
daily basis they are constantly under
some kind of a dome so it is very
difficult to influence them when you
start impacting a person he begins to
address in a prayer indeed many of them
are very different from those who come
to church only when everything is bad in
their life they come to pray and then
for 5 years they forget about God some
cannons and so on Muslims as a rule
passion believe and compassionately give
energy to their aggregor and this aggor
protects them very well that's why it is
very difficult to work to make any kind
of influence on a true Muslim believer
basically it's like in in what she's
saying in the context of what she's
saying it's a barrier of sorts that is
going to allow a form of protection
among Muslims so that and that's really
interesting Kelly because that is why
people like Andrew Tate switched over
from Christianity to Islam because he
was saying that guess what guys a lot of
Christians aren't taking it seriously
they allow anything there's churches of
Beyonce churches of all kinds of
craziness where it's not even about God
anymore it's like what is going on like
either you believe it or you don't
absolutely and this egregor I've never
heard of that but that's a really
interesting concept and it really just
sounds like a built up intentional
energy from many many many people
putting intentional energy through
rituals and practices into this very
same thing focusing on and it creates
this you know this manifested thing in
in the spiritual level so that's
interesting and we've always said that
we've always believed in that and I
believe that some deities you know I
think some are based off probably like e
beings that were here and we're
worshiped wrongly but I think that
sometimes as well it's kind of the same
thing where it's so much intentional
energies are put into one concept and
that does manifest something so some de
are almost I believe like just an energy
force just like that because so many
people believed in it and I think that
also has to do with symbols like the
witch symbol which I saw on her table
there I forget what that's called so
make sure you're praying make sure
you're saying prayed up meditated up and
really doing all the practices that are
going to get you to where you can't be
affected by any other people because I
truly believe that no one can affect me
no one can affect my mind or my reality
other than God so and God is within me
so whatever God wants will happen to me
no witch can control it no outside
entity can control no Jin can trick me
noan can get in the way of what God is
doing in my life and in my reality and
if you think in that way and if you
truly believe it and you know that no
matter what happens God is on your side
God is within you God is with you and no
witch no shatan no demon no devil no
trickery can be formed in the presence
of God because God is going to be in
control so let God be in control of your
life and don't even mess with this kind
of stuff guys stay protected at all
times I mean one thing that I love about
the energy both of them is the following
that which is very interesting this
concept we have in Islam is that the
prophet peace him said that Allah is to
God is to his servant how he thinks of
him how you think of God is how you will
find him to be so it's very interesting
you guys do meditation Etc but one thing
that I want to tell you guys is that
Islam is true not because of his being
pragmatic not because his adherence are
strictly following Muslims Etc following
practicing individuals that's not why
Islam is truth because what Christianity
can come come back and um it adherence
could be more strictly than Muslims it
doesn't show that Islam is true because
of that because it does that's that's
subjective Islam is trueth because
inherently there are so many evidences
and miracles and the Quran prophecies
there's so many things the Quran itself
tells you to test it so I want to
inshallah say to you guys that the
energy is really good the belief you
have in God and let me tell you
something the energy he has when he's
like no Shan no Jin nothing can touch me
I'll be honest with you if I just heard
this guy Muslim the certainty the the
certainty and say he has of his
meditation whatever it is to me is
profound because lot of Muslims don't
have this Muslims are more afraid of Jin
and shaan and they think as if that is
stronger than God almighty so I love his
firm like How firm he is and if he
became a Muslim he'll be an amazing
Muslim and his wife or girlfriend who is
for that matter these individuals are as
you can see there are qualities that
they have in them that if they came to
Islam it would truly Blossom so I want
to send them a guided free prayer mat
absolutely free they can try this and
pray the all the instructions are there
you can see it for yourself all the
instructions are there you can go to
Salah plus.com and order it or message
me on Instagram Alid dawa no space and
message me and I would love to send two
one for your wife and one for yourself
in
and you can use it cuz you do meditation
I highly advise you and recommend you to
do this and for us one thing that I want
to say is that we believe that as you
said God there has to be one true God
and that God if he has sent us here he
has to give us a prescription a tell us
how to live our life and meditation is
something that you do where did you get
this from is this from God how do we
know so these things are very important
that's the reason why we have the five
daily prayers and all these rituals and
the stuff that we do because we believe
they are ordained by God God did not put
us Earth for us to find ways of
connecting to him and how to connect to
him that's the reason why we are taught
how to pray the forms of praying how
many times we have to pray a day the way
we need to pray what we need to recite
these are all the things that's been
stipulated and ordered to us from God
Almighty that is the true form of
worshiping him and not only that he has
to tell us how to worship him not vice
versa of we thinking that this is the B
best way of worshiping him it's like
imagine if you guys have a child one day
and imagine your child is telling you
how they believe that they should show
how how they love you you'll say no no I
love my love language is this you would
tell them how you want respect how you
want love not vice versa by them telling
you no but I love you in this way so
this is the reason why we believe it's
so important to have that relationship
with God Almighty I would love to send
you guys a Quran if you guys haven't
don't have one and I would like to send
you a free guided prayer mat it's
absolutely free for you guys to learn
and try the method of Muslims of
learning how to pray I love the energy I
ask God Almighty to guide you guys to
straight path and we believe that
straight path is Islam and thank you for
watching these videos guys once again
brothers and sisters we are building a
brand new ABS salar plus.com Salah Plus
app and Salah plus website where people
would order guided prayer mats the
10,000 that we sent out a couple of
years ago the 20,000 we're going to send
out they can order they can book a Salah
instructor they can book a Quran
instructor they have video visual videos
showing them how to pray Salah they have
a Salah their local Salah times um uh
find so they know what's the what's the
time to pray free k finder it gives you
a notification the best time to pray not
only that we have local Salah Hub
locators where they can find their local
Salah workshops today is a day before
fud we need to reach our Target of
£15,000 please donate whatever you can
imagine you played a part in this app
being developed which you can see on my
left hand side on my right hand side
imagine for the next 10 20 years this
app is serving the umah 100,000 people
and plus what in 10 years could be
learning how to pra Salah be a part of
this opportunity in inshallah it is a
onetime offer inshallah the link is
there